elle pas en face à soan et parfois
jamais d un porte-clés il veut même pas
l'aider c'est quoi c'est quoi la mafia
la mafia c'est tout coeur qu'une culture
c'est super que l'équivalent petit
contact tout mentionné nick junior est
ce que c'est toujours la même réponse
la veille j'avais connu monsieur nick
que senior non non non j'aime rencontrer
être en train de nous dire que vous
étiez un baisser les incompétents
écoutez je pense pas être imbécile je
pense pas être incompétent non plus et
quand on est ministre il faut ériger un
mur et c'est ce que j'ai fait je veux
poser parce qu'on a un italien que l'on
fait partie de ce que les morgans
moi je poignets avec un acide gras
disque s'appelle jocelyn dupuis